after more than a month-long hiatus
finally it's back
longleat became the world's first safari
park outside of africa
in 1966 and today it had the weather
to match much to the joy of keepers and
residents
it almost feels like a bit of the soul
isn't here when we don't have people
i felt a little bit selfish over the
last year that i've had these animals
almost all to myself so
being able to share them with everyone
again is just a great feeling
the sunshine kicking off not only the
bank holiday but half term breaks in
style too
all the kids feel so excited it's like
they've not been out for like years
it's so amazing and we feel so lucky
that after
such a long time we can be outside
it's been an unseasonal month with hail
falling in london and kent
and heavy showers making a meal out of
outdoor dining
but this week some parts of the uk are
said to be warmer than ibiza
this month has been dominated by wet
weather so it's no wonder people are out
making the most of the sunshine
but where this park would normally
welcome some 10 000 visitors a day
during a typical
sunny spell that number has had to be
significantly
scaled back and for good reason
wiltshire may be miles from the places
seeing a rising cases of the indian
variant
but we know this virus doesn't respect
county boundaries
couple lily and jordan were meant to be
in orlando celebrating jordan's sister's
birthday
both have eyes on the next date of
easing when social distancing
could be scrapped i think if people keep
doing what they're doing getting
vaccinated hand sanitising keeping their
distance
i think we should be okay if we do our
part then
hopefully the cases won't keep rising do
you worry about with it being so
busy at places like this or beaches
today that maybe the 21st of june
might be a bit of a problem with
restrictions easing even more
i think the 21st of june's probably
looking unlikely unfortunately
his caution is echoed in neighboring
western super mare
where thousands bastion 22 degrees
people have got to keep doing the the
same basic things so
mixing only in their household groups
not having too much to drink or
or letting the warm weather become an
excuse to forget some of the basic rules
keep doing those things
we can keep the case numbers low and
then hopefully we can unlock fully
in june the warmer temperatures are
teasing us with summer
many are hoping the country can stay on
track for the next
phase ahead ashton haranak sky news in
wiltshire